nick fuentes is this
uh quite right-wing uh young
internet commentator who
is apparently being persecuted by the
regime
now i say apparently or i say reportedly
because nick fuentes
says that he is on the no-fly list he
says that he went to go
on a flight to give a press conference
in florida
and and the lady at the gate check said
no you can't do that
and he said why is this an airline thing
is this a tsa thing
is this a federal government thing and
she said i can't give you any
information on that i can either confirm
or deny that you're on the list
but you are not permitted to fly
i say apparently and reportedly because
i've only ever met this guy once
and it was a dishonest interaction he
he was deceptive in his dealings with me
and i didn't know who he was
and so i don't know i don't know if his
account is trustworthy but
i'm going to go on the assumption that
it is because
skeptical as i am of this guy i'm very
very skeptical of the federal government
i'm seeing what they're doing to rudy
giuliani and i'm seeing what they've
done to donald trump and i'm seeing what
they do
to conservatives all the time
consider let's say the worst opinion you
could possibly have about this guy nick
fuentes
do you really think that
it is just that he is not permitted to
travel
he a guy who has not been accused of or
convicted of any crime to my knowledge
he should not be allowed to get on an
airplane but
patrice culler's the head of black lives
matter she is she's cool
runs an organization runs a political
movement
that burned down the country last year
she's allowed to travel wherever she
wants
she gets flown around to travel all over
the place but
this guy nick fuentes is not because he
holds opinions
that are radical and that the regime
does not approve of
patrice cullers holds very radical
opinions that the regime does approve of
so she gets to do whatever she wants and
her movement burned down the country
doesn't matter consider nicole hannah
jones is that her name yes
nicole hannah jones is the head of the
1619 project at the new york times
totally lied the whole the whole premise
of the pulitzer prize-winning 1619
project
is the lie that the american revolution
was started to preserve
slavery the
political philosopher charles kessler
during the blm riots last year
he came out and he said i'm going to
start calling these the 1619 riots
because i think the 1619 project was
responsible for it
do you know what nicole hannah jones
said she said i'm proud of that oh great
please i'm honored that you would call
these riots the 6019 riots
claiming responsibility
bragging that she incited these riots
that woman is still allowed to get on an
airplane but nick fuentes is not
yeah but nick fuentes holds radical
opinions that i find very distasteful
yeah
sure what about nicole hannah jones
she holds very radical opinions that i
find very very distasteful
and she's claiming to have incited these
riots
but she gets not only does she get to
fly
somebody tells me she gets flown around
all over the place
there is big money and big privilege for
radicalism
in favor of the liberal regime
and there would appear to be again i
don't know if it's true or not
tucker carlson the other night last
night or the night before mentioned this
story and he said the same thing we
haven't been able to verify this is true
but it would seem that the right gets
persecuted
and from what's going on with rudy
giuliani it would seem
that the right even a much much more
mainstream right wing figure
for a mayor of new york former lawyer
for the president gets persecuted
and it would seem you all know this
that the right-wingers in this country
play by a different set of rules
blm burns down the country they face
very few consequences
the horn guy jumps into the capital on
january 6th and dances around the desk
all those people are facing very very
serious consequences getting pinched by
feds
told that it's an insurrection the left
burns down the country that's a peaceful
protest
the right goes in and disrupts the
capital that's an insurrection
watching watching this speech last night
it was a very eerie feeling i visited
washington dc
many times since january 6. dc
looks like a war zone it looks like one
of the places that the liberal regime
would occupy in the middle east
barbed wire up fencing up the military's
still there
national guards still occupying dc joe
biden giving this speech to a muzzled
audience
in a mostly empty room it
it made me wonder huh is that what
if this is if this is not the
insurrection what does the insurrection
look like
because this is when i think of
insurrection i don't know when i think
of a coup
it's it doesn't seem very very easily
distinguished from what
this is raises lots of questions
about the difference between how the
government is supposed to work on paper
and the way the government works
in practice hey hold on if by some
strange
chance we are still on youtube right now
i need you to ring
the button and smash the doodad and hit
the gizmo i don't know man i don't know
what you you'd say
subscribe to this channel so that you do
not miss a single video
because i'll tell you the powers that be
they don't always love our content
okay so just make sure you subscribe
right now ring that bell
and that way you will get to see all of
these pearls of wisdom
coming up
you